all right well welcome everybody today
number two have you got a love front end
I'm very happy to be here and thank you
for coming to to to my talk my name is
John and I'm from Intuit and originally
I was an investment guy I wasn't a tech
guy I worked as an investment analyst
for a little while I decided that the
technology that we use the software that
we use for investments was way more fun
so I went back to school studied a
little bit of computer science came out
I got a job as a web engineer in a small
start-up in tel-aviv
and then I moved on to intuit which is a
financial technology company a financial
software company so I'm happily exactly
where I want to be and great so into it
offers a lot of products for people who
are trying to manage their finances
whether you're a person an individual a
family or you're a small business or a
self-employed company and then we have
lots of products and I'm happy to help
people manage their finances better as a
web engineer and creating awesome
experiences that make it easy for them
to manage their finances so what are we
going to talk about quickly Phil what
typescript in existing JavaScript that's
0 because of obvious reasons no it's not
he says I'm not gonna touch too much
that's what we're talking about and do
why why is this an important thing
because we have to stop thinking that
JavaScript anti script are enemies
they're actually a story of coexistence
and hopefully I'll be able to convince
you too that the who Metallica fans
anyone nice not enough but ok
who is this going to help who is this
ultimately for why why can't a script
help solve some problems for you for
some people and the where where are we
gonna start attacking this subject in in
our projects and then the help alright
so let's get started the why
let's end these religious wars for once
and for all
a show of hands please who has tried
typescript that's actually a very good
amount have you used it in production
have you pushed it to production nice
who has had a negative experience I also
had some negative experience who had
positive experience awesome this is a
very good very good crowd
now the let's get let's get a few things
straight here this is a graph I'm maybe
it's a bit too small for the people at
the back but this is a github graph on
the most popular languages per project
and I'll zoom in to the top right and
JavaScript is right there it is the most
popular language on github right now but
typescript is right right very very
close to it it's right up there with go
in fact it's a bit more popular than go
and this is not to be overlooked I
understand that our keynote speaker Kyle
Simpson made a few good points yesterday
saying maybe typescript does not solve
his problems and the way he wants them
solved and I can respect that I get that
but this cannot be overlooked this is a
lot of popularity this is a lot of
demand this might you know this might
mean something because I don't know if
you guys saw in his talk yesterday and
his slides he showed a snippet of what
es4 would have looked like he has four
never made it to production but it kind
of looks like time so because is like a
strongly typed version so es4 I read
somewhere that was it never made it to
the standards because Microsoft was kind
of being pushy about it and some other
people didn't like it and in the end
typescript made its own ps4 into the
typescript project so now we have it and
we can use it and it's very popular and
just a note on that if you know
typescript you know JavaScript don't
pretend that tasks using javascript are
completely different languages they are
the same language you phenotypes but you
should know JavaScript don't think of it
as a completely new language and if you
know JavaScript you know typescript
you're just a bit rusty
alright the learning curve is very small
now you wrote some JavaScript code
and walks into a bar whenever and at the
back sits this error who's had this
error before or the other one some
object dots get ID is not a function
yeah okay that's a very good amount so
it's strong but it's not a Jedi yet so
our JavaScript and typescript friends
are the enemies are they frenemies no
they're friends typescript is like a
toolkit for JavaScript it's some sort of
a superset they market themselves as a
superset of JavaScript
it's a guardian or a champion it's an
add-on it's something that helps you
write better JavaScript right kind of
looks like that nobody messes with that
you know what I mean by the way who was
excited for the season
I can't wait did you guys see Jimmy
Fallon Aria said something yeah the
April Fool's joke okay great Game of
Thrones okay anyway JavaScript in
typescript are a story of coexistence
they're not a separation they should be
used together until tc39 or the echo
script council accepts that strongly
typing is an option for echo script they
should be used together cool cool now
let's talk about the who-who is this
going to help how can't our script help
improve existing JavaScript code now
obviously it's gonna help our customers
right because we have type safety
probably better code in production but
the customer doesn't care they're not
gonna use your app more because you use
typescript in it they don't even know
right but more importantly it's
important for the team typescript is an
automatic boost in documentation isn't
it it helps you design your code better
and it is a definition API definition
for your entire project now I'm gonna
show you a little code snippet a little
later actually let's let's jump to that
alright this is something that we're
working on right now my team and I on my
team half of my team is here we're
working on this and think about a
function called submit bank payment
right and
the parameters bank details and invoice
details and some configurations I don't
know oh here we go
configuration is some options now we
started getting lots of production
errors about like that that the bank
object is not correct in all cases why
because bank payments are done like we
are writing this code but other client
teams might be using our code and
passing their own variables own
parameters into this so now let's say
you're the new employee the new engineer
and you have to come in and write this
function is valid bank details or there
is valid invoice details how are you
even supposed to know what a bank object
should look like like how are you even
supposed to know that's what it's
supposed to be because I know an invoice
looks like that it's a huge object with
lots of keys and values some of them I
remember when I first started into it we
were working with bills and receipts and
there is a connection for example every
bill has multiple receipts there's an
association that comes from the back end
but when I tried to write a typescript
definition for it it was huge it was
such a big learning curve and I said how
did the last team work on this wall
because they wrote the server side and
the client side they know they know
exactly what the object looks like they
know the schema so it was easy for them
but what about the new guy what about
the the other team that's gonna take
over your project and in large
organizations this is a very typical
story you don't always end up at the
same team that you're working on the
same project that you're working on you
hire new engineers you hire junior
engineers who may not have the the sort
of the production experience that you've
had right so always think of the new guy
am i clear on this like it's so
important to be able to release think
about the situation where your server
team produces type definitions for what
an invoice or a bank account looks like
that's the dream
then the client-side engineer can take
those type definitions and plug them
into the project and work with them now
you know exactly what what a schema
looks like what the bank or invoice
schema looks like all right so now where
do we start attacking this all right so
there are lots of opinions on
how should we start writing typescript I
I know a lot of teams that are trying to
convert their entire projects to
typescript and that requires major
refactoring and sometimes it's not easy
to do sometimes it's not good to do all
right let's pick a good spot to enter
and then start from there let me give
you an example think about a let's say a
reacts project hypothetical reacts
project where you have three components
three react components these are the
ones that are facing the user the most
out facing components and they depend on
some shared component they can be
extending this class they could be using
this class as a higher-order component
and this shared component utilizes some
module that you wrote maybe some logic
code or some functional some pure
functions that run some logic and an NPM
library maybe this is a bit abstract so
let me sort of take this down to the
real world this is what I'm working on
right now this is a bank form for the
user all right as you can see every
single input has some sort of a label
and it has an input field right so it's
it's very calm it's very typical for
teams like us to sort of like have one
reused component called like a labeled
input and then the routing number
component will extend that so we'll the
account number component right and I'll
add a little twist to this they also
have to make sure that validations are
done correctly and we're not using
standard HTML validations we're using
our custom validations because of
styling reasons or logic all right so so
what would that chart look like we have
three components account number routing
number and account holders name and they
all extend to this class called
validated labeled input and the
validated labeled input depends on maybe
show error it's a utility function that
we wrote and it's gonna determine
whether this current input value is
validated correctly or is it whether
it's wrong and what kind of message to
show and it's internationalized
and we're using an NPM called validation
some bank validation NPM it doesn't
matter it's hypothetical so let's go
back to the original chart this is what
a very typical react component looks
like at least ours the the validated
labeled inputs right so where do we
start attacking word which one do we
convert the type script first always
start at the deep end of the dependency
graph the code that has the most clients
or the code that is reused the most
should be converted first all right
so phase one the utility module and the
NPM library if you start here then
you're gonna see a huge boost in your
type safety and it's gonna be easier to
convert the next phase and the next
phase is the shared component now the
shared component can utilize the type
safety that it depends on for free code
that it depends on for example the
utility module and the NPM library now
it's easier to convert the shared
component which is the validated labeled
input into type script and after that
maybe to convert the the most outward
facing components to type script you
don't have to it's maybe because it
doesn't have clients it's easy enough
right
JavaScript and test script can coexist
remember don't let your OCD take over
and convert everything to test you do
not have to in fact I'm gonna make
another claim I prefer and I urge that
you don't write unit tests in typescript
because let's say I have my utility
module write this utility module is a
pure function that doesn't have any side
effects
it takes some values and it spits out
some validation error this routing
number is invalid or something like that
right now what if this utility module
gets reused by another team they don't
know what the functions signature what
if they send and no right I want a unit
test that what if I send a null into
this into this function does it behave
correctly
well typescript unit tests will never
never let you pass null into that
function unless you start doing as any
as any as any as any you guys know what
I'm talking about right that's not
useful I'm urging you to write unit
tests in JavaScript because it's like a
dumber version of user using that
function or whatever it is that you're
testing so I urge you guys not to
convert everything to typescript all
right I know it's not a very type
scripting thing to say but like I urge
you guys to remember we are JavaScript
if we start moving away from JavaScript
ifs one day typescript team decides that
they're not following the Ekman script
conventions if they say if they start
releasing features that are not in
JavaScript or they're never gonna be in
JavaScript then maybe we go back to what
kyle simpson is saying about how the
machine javascript or all of these
spin-offs of javascript are starting to
diverge and we're losing our open
community I agree with him the
typescript team always talks about how
they release echo scripts standards a
couple of weeks later in their nightly
releases this is very important we are
JavaScript okay we're just doing it a
bit more safely oh what about the NPM
library right because nobody's gonna go
into their node modules directory and
change some code into that case right
I'm sure all of you know they have
typescript don't worry
most of the NPM libraries these days are
actually they either are written in
typescript or they provide type
definition in the @ types collection all
right so this is our entry point to
recap go at the deep end of the
dependent dependency graph convert those
first if you'd like and then move on to
the the less depend the less depending
components and convert them it gets much
easier anyway all right the hell and I
urge you guys to sort of pull out your
labs s if you want and try this if you
guys have never used these things we're
gonna go in phases phase number one
always install the type definitions of
the NPM libraries that you use all right
if you do this it's typescript enough
trust me and we do this in our team all
the time and it really helps us let me
give you an example let's say you have a
JavaScript project okay and it uses
react it has react Dom and it uses a
credit card validator library card
called card validator all right and I
believe this is important by the way the
ide that we're seeing here is Visual
Studio code in Visual Studio code if I
hover over the render function of react
it says loading okay now I don't know
what the render function signature is I
know most of us know react a little bit
or angular at least like angular angular
is written in typescript so that's a
different story but we know what the
react render react Dom render does but
take this as a point as to we don't know
what the function signature is if this
wasn't react Dom it was if it were a
more obscure library wouldn't we
wouldn't know what this function
signature would look like so oh by the
way this is IntelliJ
same store in IntelliJ it just says that
it's a function now let's do this npm
install save dev types of reactant types
of react dom now what happens if I go
back to my IDE I get the function
signature and actually I didn't even
know that there is a call back at the as
a third parameter did you guys know that
I didn't know that it's like okay step
number two maintain definition files so
typescript in general is like TS files
yes you write type script like that
however you can write JavaScript like
most NPM libraries do you can write in
JavaScript and write a definition type
script file right next to it then you
don't have to touch your JavaScript but
you can still define what the function
signature or that or that module does or
what the schemas are and all of that and
this will really help you because of the
power of your IDE okay so you write
JavaScript files you write definition
files there is no compilation you know
transpilation you're still writing good
old JavaScript but your IDE knows let's
see an example
this is a library module that I wrote
called utils as you can see it's
JavaScript and I'm using an NPM library
in here called the card validator and
I'm extracting some some utility
functions that come with this NPM and
I'm gonna write my version of the
validate okay
I want the client code to send some
values to me and I'm going to validate
them and then I'm gonna figure out what
was wrong with the card number or the
CVV number or the expiration date and
I'm gonna return internationalized error
messages back to the user via a callback
alright now this is what a definition
file would look like i have a function
called validate you can send an ID as a
string and the value as a string and
then send a callback of type validation
callback what does that mean I define it
in line seven it's a function that takes
errors which is a validation error array
and it doesn't return anything it's void
it's a closure for the client code to be
able to access all the validation errors
or the validation error messages which
are now internationalized what is a
validation error type it's a string now
this could turn into an enum one day it
can be an object it doesn't matter what
it is but as long as it's defined it's
good why now I go to my client code that
uses this validate function and I hover
over it and I see the exact definition
of it right here now I didn't use real
types I didn't convert anything I didn't
transpile or compile but look at the
power you're giving the developer I
don't know if you guys have experience
sort of like new engineers coming onto
your coming to your team but it's very
difficult to for them to take their
first task and understand exactly how
the project works they're gonna try and
spend a couple of weeks just trying to
understand your architecture and now
you're giving them a task to do
and they don't even know the function
signature sure go ahead
[Music]
that's a very good if I don't have this
project open right now if you're willing
to try something like this that would be
great I can share my get I'm pretty sure
it will autocomplete and if not it'll
give you like squiggly if you make some
if you make a mistake it'll give you
like a squiggly underline saying this
doesn't fit because the IDs are powerful
enough to know type definitions and show
even if you're working on a JavaScript
file
alright right I had to add this it's
like magic
all right
third level okay your salt on that
you're sold on this it's good
typescript definitions are working well
but now we actually want to do some type
scripts okay so the the first level of
sort of writing type scripts in your
project I say go with the Babel type
scripts preset your writing type script
files okay and you're letting Babel
transpile it's not the actual typescript
compiler okay and we'll talk about why
this is a good stepping stone to move
into the tax code compiler okay
Babel typescript preset is relatively
new and I heard about it a few months
ago and it doesn't actually compile
typescript it removes typescript
syntax which allows the rest of the
Babel transpiler transpilers to take it
and put it in your bundle so let's see
this in action first we need to add
texture to the project so npm install
typescript you create a TS config file
alright by running this command and the
TS config file I'm not gonna go over
this it's basically a bunch of
configurations for your task and
compiler to look at your project how to
perceive your project it has some
configurations on compilation you can
specify which what kind of target you
want it to be if you know you have to be
backwards compatible you might want to
choose target as es5 and things like
that which files they include which
files to exclude like node modules and
how to deal with existing JavaScript in
your project it's actually pretty handy
and it also lets you do experimental
type script features such as decorators
alright so we've created a type script
configuration file great now we
officially have a type scripts project
now create the utils the same module
that I had about the validation function
with the callback created in TS make
sure you've deleted the utils J s and
DTS while I was debugging I spent 20
minutes on trying to understand why it
wasn't working that's because I wrote
the utils TS but I didn't remove the
utils J s and the DTS alright so this is
what it looks like it's kind of like a
merge of the utils J s and the
definition file I'm importing all the
functions that I need from the card
validator NPM I define what a validation
error looks like and I define what a
callback that uses it looks like and
then I export the actual validate
function I cut out the rest of this you
you guys basically understand it's a
function that takes a string a value as
ID a value of string and a callback
which is of type validate callback it'll
do its work and then it's going to
invoke the callback function with the
found errors right now I go back to my
client code which is form input and
instead of importing the utils I'm going
to import utility s this may not be
necessary anymore the babble compilers
are updating themselves so that you
don't have to maybe add the TS extension
but will it compile who says yes well it
won't because can't resolve utils in my
project
all right that's correct because we need
to tell webpack to recognize typescript
files first alright so let's do that
this is what the web pack looks like now
it's gonna look like this cool I'll let
you guys yeah
sorry how about now well it's not gonna
compile because we don't know how to
read typescript files yet we're talking
about babel typescript reset but i
didn't show you guys how to add that
first so let's do that
NPM install babel preset typescript it's
awesome and in your babel RC file or
babel configuration file
you add the babel typescript to the
array of presets how about now well it
works it's awesome this is Amy Wambach
she's great alright nice so we have a
type script project and it's working and
we have injected some decent touch
script into our project but are we
getting any type scripts help which is
compilation errors if we make a mistake
let's trigger an error and see it
alright we know that there is this
function that comes from the card
validator npm and it's supposed to take
value of type string and what if i do
what if I just pass a boolean in there
right first of all my IDE knows because
it has type definition that's and that's
powerful enough right but what about the
compilation it worked
why because remember Babel preset type
scripts does not compile but it rather
removes the typescript syntax so if you
want strict type security which is the
ultimate typescript feature then you can
do one of two things one start another
shell process and run TSC which is the
typescript compiler and watch your
errors there while you're using the
babel presets to bundle you can use
another process to see your compilation
errors or you can do the ultimate thing
which is the last stage of our how to
inject typescript into your existing
project which is the typescript compiler
this is just writing TS files or
definition files and this is the real
deal so let's take our project that
we've worked on on step 3 and turn it
into an actual type script project now
most of the work was done currently
we have our babel configurations look
like this we have the babel preset type
script and our web pack looks like that
first thing that we're going to do is
relieve babel of its duties
we don't need babel for type script
anymore the second thing is we're going
to add another loader for web pack so
that it can recognize and compile
typescript and add it into our bundle i
like awesome type script loader there is
also TS loader
they're both greats the only reason why
i prefer to awesome type script loader
so far was that its source maps were a
bit better it was easier to debug
but maybe TS loader caught up already
I'm really not trying to pick sides here
so now the web pack configuration looks
like this we're gonna take the
typescript extensions out of the babel
loader and we're gonna put it into
another clause that's going to use
awesome typescript loader so basically
web pack is going to use the awesome
typescript loader if it comes across a
type script file great it's working
immediately I didn't have to do anything
do we have type security now as you know
this is what I tried to do I tried to
pass a I try to pass a boolean into a
function that accepts a string and bam I
get an error immediately alright
so to recap don't think of typescript as
another language you are using
javascript in the end and stick to that
and always bet on JavaScript just like
kyle simpson said yesterday make sure
that we let's make sure that we
understand that this is a toolkit and we
need to use it for our customers but
more so we need to use it for our
teammates we need to use it for the next
team to take on this project or we need
to use it so that if we are writing some
code that other clients are going to use
other client teams are going to use
we're helping them out by boosting our
documentation but by boosting our api's
by using typescript all right and if you
want if you're sold on this idea and if
you want to start using
there are some levels in which you can
do it there are some things that you can
do right now you can do this right now
at the break step number one install
type definitions from NPM for all the
libraries that you're using and push
that to production it's fine this
doesn't affect your code anyway the
second thing that you might want to do
is maintain definition files for your
existing JavaScript file modules and
this helps you by looking at your by
making your IDE much more powerful and
giving you warnings and errors on things
that you may not have caught because we
let's face it where we all go through
refactoring and when you go through
refactoring sometimes you miss things
third level is using this awesome handy
thing from Babel called the Babel type
script preset where you're writing
typescript but but Pat Babel will try
and spoil that for you by removing the
typescript syntax and in the end if you
want to do the real thing you include a
typescript compiler in your bundling
process and you have real time script in
production and that's it
thanks very very much